good morning good morning good morning
ahoy there Oh my dog just left right
when I said good morning well welcome to
the right 10 club everyone whoa whoa are
the sound effects working can y'all hear
the applause let me know if you can hear
the applause but welcome to the right 10
club this is where we meet up at 10 a.m.
to right for 10 minutes every single day
so whether you're a comedian like me and
several of you out there just someone
looking to create a productive morning
habit or someone just looking for a
creative space
welcome to the right 10 club so we are
actually streaming on Facebook and
YouTube today we're getting fancy out
here alrighty so we're gonna be trying
some things first off
sounds like tie so silly said you can't
hear the sound effects so can you hear
I'm playing music right now
can you hear any music right now what's
up what's up 5,000 light years away
look at this we're on YouTube right now
morning EJ morning no sound effects they
say good morning dawn nope nope well
isn't that Pleasant don't you love when
you try something new
and it just isn't yes okay everyone I
get it there's no music
thank you for your overwhelming response
to my failure as a live streamer thank
you so much so that's a bit unfortunate
I will say that
slightly unfortunate I will say but what
are you gonna do yo what's up Roman
what's up what's up ty so silly learning
curve that's right ty so silly that's
right
Oh looks like we have a Eric Taoist
saying you just sold me on this
broke-ass program what's wrong what's
wrong with the program I'm confused I
mean I don't know what I don't know what
happened I've been using it for like two
and half weeks it's been great
I'm trying an additional program called
stream yard right now because I'm trying
to ah
yes no sound effects yeah the no sound
effects is because I'm going through a
third party so it's trying to stream to
multiple places at once so I was trying
this program called stream yard that I
was apparently get you out on more
platforms than one and but apparently I
can stream on multiple but the sound
effects aren't coming through from the
ECAM program so isn't that fun but I
also wanted to kind of gauge just what
what kind of engagement we would get on
[Music]
YouTube as well because we're
experimenting here and we're growing
here you know so I just want to make
sure we're getting out to as many people
as possible I mean it sounds like right
now we have a one person two people are
watching on YouTube so we're getting
fancy out here just no sound effects so
that's a good thing to know for the
future
is that the sound effects from ECAM are
not gang in the stream yard but no need
to get into the technical jargon Andy
likes it morning Trent probably more
trance prom transferring to YouTube yeah
it's um it's a third party thing but as
Tyler said the show must go on and Oh
Eric's just given me a hard time thank
goodness I was like man my heart's
broken I love I really liked using ECAM
and I like to tell people about it but I
don't want people to feel like I'm some
sort of pyramid scheme or with this I'm
just trying to do the right thing ah but
Eric's it's all good what you're doing
is awesome thank you so much Eric but if
you think about it I mean look how much
we've already changed I mean if you look
at the room I mean come on look at look
at what's happening here people so it's
all incremental building and those of
you who have been here since the
beginning can see major Ness
like we're making major changes pretty
much every single day trying a bunch of
different stuff so appreciate y'all
hanging out with me as we're going
through this and learning this together
we got three people watching on YouTube
that's so great and and 22 on Facebook
so clearly there's um there's something
going on here but it's also kind of like
you get the results where you put the
attention so a lot of my attention has
been on Facebook good night
this says 61 shares what that can't be
right
good night Almighty 61 shares what in
tarnation well thanks for sharing y'all
let me see here yes Robin it is it's
about the writing not the sound effects
that's right but the sound effects are
registering dawn the sound effects are
registering it says 61 shares so thank
you to everyone that shared and what I'm
thinking alright Todd thanks for
stopping by we'll see you tomorrow good
luck in your meeting be safe out there
mica says no horn no shares I feel you I
feel you but what I'm thinking here is
before we jump into the writing is um
what I'm thinking it's more about excuse
or experience though so I would rather
do one streaming very well with sound
effects and of like overlays and all
that as opposed to trying to stream
everywhere mediocre ly you know what I
mean so um I think that's something we
learned today so that's good to know
good to know sound effects aren't
working which is great so oh but from
YouTube look 5,000 light years away said
I've been working on material through
the night well you are in the right
place my friend because right 10 club is
where we write for 10 minutes so we're
gonna write work on a little bit of
material and then get on with your
Tuesday did anyone see my review if
you're not growing you're slowing and if
you're not failing you're not trying
that's what I always say so I won't say
today's a fail I'll say we learned a lot
today you know it's just eating me on
that one bite at a time as they say but
that's exciting
so let's what we do here for the people
that don't know we get a random word and
then we write for 10
it's so that's what we're going to do
today and hey hey hey so let me jump
into we have EJ masa Campo a comedian in
North Carolina who always prompts us
thank you to everyone that has shared
this sorry
sound effects aren't going today but we
learned that tomorrow we will just keep
it on Facebook so those of you watching
on YouTube
go join Facebook and we're writing on
there every day but it just doesn't seem
[Music]
like it wasn't time yet one bite at a
time
so that's that's good to know so with
all that being said EJ do you have the
word of the day do you have it
yes Eric said it should be yes I should
have like a real horn or a slide whistle
[Music]
or my dog look at him we did so anyway
got a shoehorn four shares that's funny
hash browns in the kitchen wrist twisted
like it's stir-fry all right well anyway
it's good to know that one bite at a
time don't want to get don't want to
overextend yourself so for the future we
will just keep it to Facebook until we
figure this out oh but that is so nice
umm from YouTube said no one seems to
care about the sound effects you've been
really worried about not everyone is on
social media I think you're doing fine
that is so kind thank you so much 5,000
light-years away oh you're right on time
areia we're just about to start sip of
gin 4shared that's right well here we go
it appears we do have the word of the
day where to go where to go oh here we
go alright kids this is a good this is a
good prompt for the day the word of the
day
smother the word of the day is smother
so do with that what you will and it's
all what you can do with the word
smother is you can write about the
actual word smother you can do what
we've discussed in here before the a to
see where smother makes me think of this
that makes me think of that or you can
write about whatever you want for the
next 10 minutes this is all about just
committing to writing doodling drawing
it's just throwing your day off the
right way as we say here so excuse me
with all that being said we are going to
jump right in to write 10 in 3 2 oh no
wait I don't even know how to do this
cuz I'm can you see this oh yeah that's
showing oh hold on we're learning there
we go there's the timer will reset it
and let's write
[Music]
you random word is smother
alright alright there it is our first
ever multi stream right teen club I
think this was a great success how do
you all feel about it out there thank
you so much everyone this is Ben this is
a good'n word of the day was smother for
those of you interested oh look
MMA pixels hey I watched your videos of
you working out your set awesome to see
your progression thanks thanks a lot
that actually that means a lot I'm glad
it's a tough to share those more
vulnerable moments and failures on stage
but I'm glad you find it helpful that's
that's what this whole show is about so
thank you for sharing that I really do
appreciate it that means a lot nice
Kenan the the challenge was ten minutes
of writing on the words smother if you
want or just writing in general what did
you guys find for the word smother
steve-o eh whoa on YouTube he had a
blast with a bunch of comments do more
Joel alrighty then hmm
whoo OH zap punk says smother equals Sam
morels mother okay
I'm car Oh
Tariq's has been preoccupied but still
grateful to you for doing this thank you
so much to Rick I really do appreciate
that that keeps us going here that keeps
us going here oh this is fun sandy said
I'm sneaking away from work to do this I
came up with a couple I put on so many
layers of homemade face masks when I go
to the store that I am more likely to
smother myself then die of code 19 I
love she's sneaking away from work to do
this that's so funny
that's funny and sandy said my husband
and I are so sick of being in quarantine
with one another that the only pillow
talk what's going to happen will be
someone begging for mercy as their bigs
oh that's good that's good Oh Tyler said
the my pillow guy look at all these
jokes coming in this is great
Trent said any words associated with
smother I thought of smother brothers
and thought of the my pillow guy that's
really funny
so maybe the my pillow guy had a brother
who was the the my prison guy or my
felony guy I don't know
Tyler still like to my pillow guy I
thought that was a funny Association - I
love sandy was sneaking away from work
to do this oh snap
we're up to six people on YouTube and 15
this is so great I'm 15 on Facebook I am
loving this my friends let's see what
else who else posted Robin speaking
southern takes practice for example
smoke
there was that was that you I saw at the
barn with JimBob
no that was smother yes see Robin
and that's why we write every single day
because yesterday we were trying to
figure out how to do that with the word
iron and then look smother first try
great job Robin great job maybe want
some smothered pork chops
oh yeah Maria no better time for
smothered pork chops than 10:30 a.m.
Oh insane decent Angela Moore sent me
that's so great thanks thanks sandy
welcome to the right teen club we meet
up every day at 10:00 Angela actually
won we do competitions on the weekend
and she actually won this weekend was
great
Oh Maria Pia I wouldn't mind smothering
the pillow guy with his pillows okay
Marcus is laughing at that
oh the my pillow guy people are really
diggin that my pillow guide Trent from
YouTube 5,000 light-years away said they
could say whatever crazy thing and it's
just they're cute or quirky way of
showing love you know how often I've
heard a woman say something like have
fun but if you talk to a girl say
goodbye so would that be talking about
being smothered by someone you're dating
they can say whatever crazy thing and
it's like just they're cute or quirky
way of showing love you know I've heard
a woman say something like have fun so
what's the premise there it's what we're
looking for
oh look sandy and Dawn know each other
that's fun
I don't want to smother anyone but yeah
but a five thousand nine years away what
would be the premise of the joke there
what are you trying to convey we talked
about this with Mark Norman's qat of you
want to make the joke as simple as
possible so how can you simplify that
joke Robert when it comes to my kids I'm
the ultimates mother I will take their
lunch into their classroom I will kiss
them on social media I will be attending
their honeymoons some other problems
mm-hmm Alan J Lister I have a pasture I
have a pasture pastor at church he loves
to some other people would love he had
to move away he got someone pregnant
mm-hmm
I see what you did there Alan are you
that pastor unrelated to smother but I
wrote about baby mannequins Bravo
Christine yes this is all about just
writing in general it doesn't have to be
specific to anything unless you want it
to be that is quite a connection though
between smother and baby mannequins oh I
like how your brain works
I think I'm building a whole slower same
from your club yeah Robyn
we've you've got two so far so keep
expanding that's great
uhh
okay I see 5,000 light years away hold
on I wrote a whole bit women deal with
certain oppression but they also have
certain privileges like women and
relationships can get crazy smell of the
dude with dozens of unread messages
think you say whatever they want I see
yeah no it's a whole bit broken into
three parts the YouTube comments are a
lot more aggressive trying to find the
third part say goodbye talk to a girl to
say goodbye I'm only seeing two parts oh
there's a word limit on YouTube ah well
comedy is brevity so have to edit that
down I had ass mother mother how many
dads can one go through ah Vanessa ray I
miss waffle house covered in smothered
Micah listen to John Skype session
yesterday loved how you tried to apply
the power of threes to his joke with the
ancestry Oh
Thank You Micah yeah that's a good one
if y'all haven't heard hot breath
episode this week was a skype session
that I'll do with comedians to help them
punch up jokes or help them find new
more personal material so Micah actually
did one and let me post it on the
podcast as well so if anyone out there
watching is interested in doing a Skype
session just shoot me a message and
let's do it I also do set reviews if you
just have like a five-minute set you
want some feedback on then holla at your
boy I'm happy to help
she said smoother but I ended up
smothering her ah I see a little
wordplay there sab reach all the way
from India Trent said if I were Eve I
would I would have smothered Adam's ribs
and barbecue sauce just to sweeten God's
deal oh that's great
ooh bo said he's interested bow shoot me
a message and I'll get back to you after
the right ten club so Bo's interested
yeah I only do three Skype sessions a
week this week's already booked up but I
do have two more slots next week if
anyone wants to snag those and I do five
set reviews a week if anyone would like
a set review Oh Christine said that my
pillow guy did cross my mind too but he
was on my mind long before this writing
exercise people loving the my pillow guy
um from YouTube matul said or my tol
sorry I don't want to mispronounce your
name but thanks for watching I don't
think it's a coincidence that you can't
spell mother or smother without mother a
lot of mothers do smother Owen otherone
from YouTube hello please give me advice
on writing a book about my life growing
up in the foster care system how do I
start it well
this write ten club is a great place to
start we show up every day at 10 a.m.
and we write for 10 minutes so you could
join us every day and then you have 10
minutes of nothing but writing that book
and then you add those 10 minutes up
over the day over the week over the
month and then by the time you know it
you'll have a book written but starting
is the hardest part so you know what you
want the book to be about growing up in
the foster care system so just kind of
start writing even if it's starting out
with a blueprint and then filling in all
the space in there and just start off
with what is the book about what would I
want it to convey what is my mission
with the book you know I wrote a comedy
writing book and it all started off with
classes I taught that one of my students
was like hey this could be a book so we
work together on making it a book and
kind of turned in my eight-week comedy
class into and of a
a writing guide for comedians to help
them take thoughts in their head and
formulate them into material then
organizes that into a set so started out
as a blueprint of like okay well what
are the major talking points of the book
I want to convey on and then we fill in
those talking points a little bit of
okay what are the specific exercises
within each of those talking points that
I can convey so it's kind of starting
broad and then narrowing it down over
time but starting is the hardest part
hope that helps a bunch of words is like
a one-minute bit you're right I'm sorry
friend I'm just trying to help here I
only saw two parts of the three-part I'm
here to help though buddy I hope that
helped you me always Bose says my
girlfriend wanted to break up because I
was smelling her apparently take my
breath away was a song I like that my
girlfriend wanted to break up because I
was smothering her apparently take my
breath away
was a song that's good yes Steve were in
demand huh mm-hmm
thanks for engaging over on YouTube Rock
10 a.m. Eastern yes we're here everyday
10 a.m. Eastern you're welcome Steve
awesome thank you I will show up yeah
awesome looks like we're have to keep on
YouTube here shrimp bad my mom smothered
me with love she did my laundry until 18
days ago I'm 33 and I missed and I miss
my starched boxer shorts there may be
room for like a quarantine joke in there
to Trent but I think it's um she did my
laundry until 18 days ago just I
wouldn't say 18
pause 18 days ago it would be 18 pause
days ago
and then I'm 33 and missed my starts
boxer shorts
there could be a tag in there I would
like this quarantine has killed my
starch game or something you know Joel
did you see my pillow guy one of the
clown show briefings oh no I did not see
that I'll have to check it out
matul Mitel I'm sorry no setups so
what's a smother fussa kept thinking of
punchlines no setups yeah it's all a
process though some people start with
the punchline and then fill in the setup
after some people start with the setup
and then get to the punchline some
people just have an idea that then
evolves into a punchline it's there's no
one-size-fits-all to writing that's why
in this club I don't tell you
specifically how to do anything we give
you a random word if you want to write
about it and then it's up to you to just
create because everyone has a different
system so if you're thinking a punchline
is great just brainstorm a bunch of
punchlines and then work backwards from
those yay thank you me always
no worries you're good you're good 5,000
light years
oh here's the third part of his joke to
your dick cuz I'm cutting it off but the
second you say I'm cutting your tits off
the cops show up at your door know how
purpley they're you're the next Jeffrey
Dahmer not trying to sound aggressive or
anything he says that was aggressive but
that is what we're doing here is we're
using this as a sounding board to try
out material so we're all trying here so
thanks for sharing that 5,000 I'm in
California what time does your class
start for me so that would be 7 a.m.
Trent bad is all the way out in
California he's been joining us every
day so that would be 7 a.m. your time
yeah
all right
any others awesome all right well thank
you all this is this has been very
exciting you know this is our first time
live-streaming to both YouTube and
Facebook so I'm excited to see how this
can evolve over time you know what I
mean so oh dear
excuse me excuse me oh so I'm gonna
research how to get these sound effects
going in both um Trent
actually there's no live interview today
it was rescheduled to tomorrow so
tomorrow at 2:00 p.m. we'll be doing a
live Q&A with Mia Jackson she just had a
Comedy Central special
she's been on tour with Amy Schumer just
she's killing it she's been on hot
breath a couple times one of my dear
friends and comedy as well so it's gonna
be great she loves hot breath she loves
helping other comedians so tomorrow at
2:00 p.m. okay cool he always says sorry
Thank You Bo thanks so yeah tomorrow at
2:00 p.m. we're doing the live Q&A and
then Thursday as well we have a live Q&A
with dusty slay yeah so it's gonna be a
good time as he says and we're doing Q&A
every single week so we're gonna keep
turning him out but today's got
rescheduled cuz shouldn't up having
something with likes a gaffe after she
said or something I don't know some
showbiz thing she's up in New York so um
thanks for asking though thanks for
hanging out 5,000 light years thank you
everyone thank you thank you thank you
thank you for all the shares thank you
for all the gratitude I'm so grateful
for you and anyone interested in getting
a SEC review or doing a Skype session
highlights you boy
and we'll be back tomorrow at 10 a.m.
y'all I love you all so much yeah
Rama says Dusty's a bud he's gonna be
here on Thursday so it's gonna be
exciting
so thank you everyone
seriously from the bottom of my heart
this has been amazing and we're back
tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. all right now
yeah we're having a good time
have a great day I love you all so much
and appreciate all of your time
hopefully we'll see you tomorrow sandy
we're here every day at 10:00 a.m. with
me you and my dog bye Maria thanks for
hanging out y'all we'll see you tomorrow
10:00 a.m.